كل الاعين على وزيره الداخليه البريطانيه
ومشروعها في الحد من الهجره بعد الكشف
الصادم عن اعداد المهاجرين في المملكه
المتحده
على عاتقها مهمه انهاء ازمه المهاجرين لكن
كل المؤشرات تظهر عكس ذلك فقد وصل صافي
اعداد المهاجرين الى المملكه الى اكثر من
606 الاف شخص في 2022
اي بزياده
164 الف شخص مقارنه ب 2021
فيما تجاوز اجمالي اعداد المهاجرين الى
المملكه العام الماضي المليون ومائه الف
اي ما قد يعادل 23 الفا خلال اسبوع واحد
واكثر من ثلاثه الاف مهاجر في اليوم مع
اصول مهاجرين من خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي
بنسبه اكبر مقارنه بالاعوام السابقه
الحكومه ارجعت الاسباب الى رفع قيود
كورونا على الطلاب وعائلاتهم بالاضافه الى
الحرب الاوكرانيه واللجوء الالاف منهم
كونغو افغانستان
اسئله كثيره تواجه رؤساء الوزراء
المتعاقبين من حزب المحافظين لماذا تعهدوا
بالسيطره على اعداد المهاجرين دون خطه
واضحه في المقام الاول اسئله بدات تسيء
الى سمعه الحزب الحاكم منذ عام 2010 وبدات
ترفع من رصيد الاحزاب المعارضه تاتي هذه
الاسئله فيما كشفت تقارير مسربه عن اليه
تدرسها وزيره الداخليه لترحيل ثلاثه الاف
لاجئ في الشهر الواحد وذلك كجزء من مشروع
قانون الهجره غير الشرعيه الذي يناقشه
مجلس اللوردات والذي يواجه عده عقبات
قضائيه وحقوقيه بالاضافه الى غياب التمويل
اللازم لتوفير المساعدات القانونيه
للاجئين وهو ما يعقد سمعه الخطه الحكوميه
المحافظه التي يسعى سوناك الى تنفيذها
ويعول عليها لرفع حظوظ الحزب في
الانتخابات المقبله من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات